[Applause]
what up what up live from the
headquarters of Ramy Solutions it's the
ramsy show where we help people build
wealth get out of debt do work that they
actually care about and learn to have
great relationships I'm John delone
joined here by about out to be
bestselling Author George camel and
we're taking your calls on money life
relationships work all of itle 8825 5225
it's 8825
5225 hopefully it's lunch after the
Monday after Thanksgiving so hopefully
your blood sugar has restabilized your
your head isn't just asleep on your desk
and you are with us you're talking
you're talking to yourself John let's be
honest I am talking to myself let's go
out to Lonnie in Athens Georgia what's
up
Lonnie Hi how are y'all could not be
better what's
up so our situation I have a 23-year-old
stepson that's on his second senior year
two more senior years left to go to get
a general business
degree and my husband pays tuition rent
utilities truck
everything for him
so when he does graduate he has stated
that he doesn't want to get a job he
doesn't want to be an adult you know
doesn't
want to do anything except for basically
live off my husband Lonnie Lonnie Lonnie
why in the world would he want to get a
job he has it made he's got the perfect
life exactly well that's what I tell my
husband I'm like why would he if you're
gonna pay for everything I mean well
it's not it's not the paying for
everything some people are able to bless
their kids that's fine it's the um it's
the way in which that blessing is
becoming a
curse that's what I'm I'm thinking um
there's no accountability with it it's
it's an ATM machine with an endless
donor yes and I'm on board with paying
for tuition for his school I feel like
after five years we should stop and if
he needs
two more years because he messed around
and lived his best life for a few years
I feel like that should be on him that
we shouldn't be on the hook you know
seven years for a general business
bachelor's degree hey Lonnie your
conversation is not with your with this
your stepson your conversation is with
your
husband yes and he is not on board but
here's here's hold on don't miss what
I'm trying to say
your anger and frustration should be
with your husband and you are not you're
refusing to to have that interaction and
so you're deflecting it on this 23y old
kid it's not the 23y old kid's fault
he's just been doing exactly what life
has presented
him as my friend Henry Cloud says he
needs some problems like rent and truck
payments and insurance but he's never
had those because of your husband not
because of something that's wrong with
your 23-year-old
right so how do I try to get my husband
on board because you know I've had the
discussion many times and his response
is you know it's my money I can do
whatever I want you know if we want to
pay that's one problem this idea that
it's all my money and so you don't get a
vote in what I do with my
money the other problem is it sounds
like he's been trying to to buy his
son's love for a long time now and if he
doesn't have this anymore the
relationship will need some actual uh
repair yes that is true so that's what's
lying underneath all this that I can
smell a mile away but the conversation
he needs to have with his son is hey
I've been doing a really terrible job
raising you into the man that I want you
to be and that you need to be and so
this looks like new boundaries new rules
as for what how this is going to happen
you're going to finish school in two
years or else I'm not paying for it
you're going to now take over the truck
payment and get a part-time job and
guess what the son's not going to like
that is he no but that's between them at
that point isn't
it yes that's you need to put the ball
back in his court and he needs to be a
man and be a husband and it needs to be
our money which means you get a vote
that's what he signed up for when he
married you isn't it yes that is correct
so here's the conversation it is not I
can't believe you're giving this kid
money I can't believe you're doing that
you know you're doing this you know
you're doing this cuz when you come at
him with a bunch of accusations he has
to defend himself that's just human
nature he doesn't have to he could curl
up in a ball but he's got to defend
himself and if you can look back at your
series of actions they haven't worked
have they it's just nagging him about
this working no it's not so let's do
something different let's take him out
how long have youall been
married um two years okay let's take him
out and say two years ago we both said I
do
and my money and my heart and my life
became yours and your money and your
life and your heart became
mine and when you say things like it's
my money I can do whatever I
want it scares me to death and I can't
breathe because I feel like I'm hanging
out here all by
myself like you're renting
me and it either has to be all of us or
or we have to have a much harder
conversation because 2 years into
marriage this isn't a marriage this is
just a a really sophisticated roommate
situation you see how one is you telling
him how you feel how scared you are how
his actions affect you and the other is
you just nagging him and throwing things
at
him one is an invitation to a
conversation a hard one the other is I'm
throwing stuff at you now I'm going to
throw stuff at you and I'm going to
throw stuff at you and then you get mad
and walk
away third or fourth down the list we'll
get to talking about how he's funding
his son's
immaturity with no end in
sight but that's not the first
conversation the first conversation is
your marriage is not as strong as you
think it is and let's be super honest
there's other things going on besides
this isn't it isn't
there no actually we have a wonderful
marriage it's just this is the only
thing that we argue
about you just described a way in which
it's not
wonderful and that is he has his stuff
and you've got
yours which means you'll have a
wonderful living Arrangement you don't
have a wonderful
marriage cuz wonderful marriage says who
are we going to be
together and how are we going to move
forward completely United getting closer
with every step we take in into the
future not this is my crap and that's
your
crap see what I'm
saying
yes that's the hard conversation to have
do you have a good relationship with him
with the
stepson um not really because we we
you're trying to ruin his life make him
pay for his own truck no we we only see
him when he wants money or needs
something from my husband no really
right I mean I think you try to invest
in this relationship and you try to help
him set some goals and dig in and make
it more than just a transaction oh I
like that idea George maybe you call him
and take him to
Coffee there's an option maybe you call
him and say hey I just wanted to get to
know you better what if we started going
to lunch together I'll cover lunch there
you go yeah I'll pay for lunch hey uh
marriage is not um you do yours and I'll
do mine it's we will do ours however
complicated that is8 825 5225 this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees every
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50% off everything
sitewide visit blinds.com today to learn
more
[Music]
Triple 8 825 5225 this is the ramsy show
uh what do we got here you know what day
it is John what day is it it's actually
this is one of my favorite days of the
year as a guy who loves a deal Cyber
Monday is my Super Bowl I don't know
anything about sports but I know a lot
about Cyber Monday and uh you know
you're waiting I know you want to make a
joke John make it uh nope I'm keeping it
shopping is considered a sport in my
household that's that's the state of
America there it is L where we're at no
literally uh on Thursday my wife uh she
doesn't listen to this show so I I she
wanted a Roomba for Christmas and so I
ordered it on Thursday and then I
thought I wonder if they'll have like a
special thing on Monday why didn't you
just text me John I could get you the
best deal on a Roomba I have my ways
yeah see I just you know what I it
wasn't worth I I my time is valuable oh
I see and it said like a cyber monday
deal on Thursday or something like that
it always does but here's the good news
Ramsey has an actual we've got an actual
one day Cyber Monday sale uh on our site
ramsy solutions.com
store and it is our prices of the year
today only this isn't like Amazon where
they just mark up the MSRP and it's like
70% off and it's the same price it
always is this is actually the best deal
of the year is a cyber monday sale so
you can get great gifts for family and
friends for as low as five bucks
including audio books and for the first
time building a non-anxious life John's
new audio book is 10 bucks for the first
time ever 10 bucks it's amazing supposed
to sit for a year before they do that
here we go in Financial Peace University
our Flagship money course is at the
lowest price of the year at just $59.99
we've we' got the 2024 Ramsey gold
planner just 40 bucks on sale and uh
we've got Dr John delon's in there
Rachel Cruz Jade warshaw they're going
to help you work on faith relationships
and finances through their monthly
teachings Rachel Cruz's new Navy wallet
is on there so you can go shop the one
day Cyber Monday sale Ramy solutions.com
store this is the time John this is the
time don't miss it you're not buying
anything today are you I hadn't thought
to but you already bought the Roomba I
I'm going to I'm going to buy some stuff
today in honor of George camel you
should go to the ramsy solutions.com
store and pre-order my new book John
that would mean the world I've I already
have that tattooed on my arm like like
honestly you have worse tattoos so I
they wouldn't Shock Me Steve in Las
Vegas and see what's up Steve what's up
Steve hey how you guys doing we're
partying man what's up I'm not just uh
just calling in um just cuz back in June
month before my son was born my mom
passed away ah I'm sorry man yeah she
left me a life insurance benefit it was
a lot more than what I expected it was
143,000 40,000 but um I do have some
debt and I was just I was kind of afraid
to spend the money towards there I just
something I don't know psychologically
it's like so hard to do because I want
to buy a house in the near
future and uh but my credit's not up to
par and I want to get it back up to
where it was but I'm just afraid of
using that money to pay off cuz I know
what you know for me like it feels like
water like it just goes away so fast
more than what I make what what's your
full Financial picture what are you
making right now what's your
income uh well I just got back to my job
in March I this is my third time being
at the same job um but I would say about
3100 per month but it depends on if the
month's good month before probably the
best month I had this year was like six
6,000 for the month is this commissions
bonuses what why' you say you're back
for the third
time well cuz in 2020 at the end of 2020
we got all that go uh cuz the the
company was in bankruptcy due to covid
and then uh four months later came back
when they reopened the store got rehired
but then I stayed almost a year and then
I quit in December for another job
because I was just tired of it and it
was inconsistent as far as you income uh
car sales but it's kind of a rental
company that sells cars
oh okay yeah and commission MH yeah I
think we need to if you're in that
business you could be making way more
money than that with more stability and
I encourage you to do that as part of
this game plan but how much debt do you
have about 52,000 including uh just a
credit card for my
wife okay does your wife work outside
the home she does not cuz she takes care
of our child and we have another a
daughter also all right what other debt
do you have outside of the credit card
so I have uh so my credit card I had
three credit cards they all got closed
back in 2022 and because I got I when I
switched to my other job I just you know
wasn't able to pay them got behind and
then I have my car loan which I owe
about
173 and then uh my personal loan for 12
Grand and another one for 5,000 but
they're all pretty much closed the only
thing that's open is my car loan and
what's in collections right
now uh I believe it's the I have two
Chase credit cards and then uh W Fargo
credit card I got a subpoena actually
for that like a month after my baby was
born and uh so I settled with them
recently so I'm just trying to wait for
them to send me paperwork to do that but
um that's pretty much all of it there
hey Steve are you sick of
this
yes like and I not sick of dtor calling
you are you sick of being a man who
keeps defaulting on his
word yeah yeah you know you know what
I'm
saying yeah I guess have you ever dated
um somebody dated a woman who just kept
cheating on you and you'd break up and
then go back with her and then she'd
cheat on you You' break up with her and
go back with
her um no never been in that situation
but you are with your professional life
why do you keep doing that with your
job and all all this is painting a
picture of a guy who kind of walks
around life with his head
down and I would love to see a Steve who
had his head held
high it was a guy who honored his word a
guy who worked hard and expected an
employer to be equally as integrous and
loyal and that they went and made a
whole bunch of money together and helped
a whole bunch of people at the same
time but I can't want that more than you
want do you want that does that even
sound
right yeah of course I mean I would like
the obviously I mean I've had some rough
couple of years after Co and uh
especially my mom dying yeah been hit in
the mouth a bunch and then all of a
sudden this you got this
gift yes and so I don't want you to
think of this as money I want you to
think of your mom's pardon gift to you
was
Freedom maybe for the first man in your
family's generation in history you're
free you can owe nobody
anything and you can quit this crap and
quit working for a crappy place that
treats you bad you can go get a job as a
Sal which hopefully you're good at and
you can provide for your family a life
of
Integrity yes you ready for that Steve
we'll lay out the game plan if you're
ready I am I know it's scary but here's
what would this would look like let's
say you have the 143,000 right sitting
in the bank mhm you paid off all 52,000
today that leaves you with 91,000
correct yes now we're going to Sock away
3 to 6 months of expenses let's go 6
months cuz your job is volatile and your
single income family so what's six
months of expenses for your house
ballpark 6 months I would say about um
grand um yeah I would say that okay so
let's say we put 20 grand aside in a
high yield savings account and we don't
touch that money unless there's a true
emergency now you're your own credit
card okay see what we're doing think
about where you're at right now you have
no debt payments and you've become your
own bank you have 20 grand sitting there
ready to protect you and you still have
$71,000 left over to become a homeowner
and do it the right way and start that
down payment
fund or that makes sense we could let
this money run like water through our
hands like you mentioned and we can go
buy some toys and emotionally spend and
put our family behind instead of
ahead yeah and that's what John's saying
this is a gift this is a life raft this
is a get out of jail free card but I
want you to use it wisely and think
about the Legacy that your mom left and
go what's the man I want to become what
kind of family do we want to have what
are what kind of where do we want to be
5 years from now 10 years from now I
want you to have a paid for house and be
investing for the
future that's what I want and I want you
to be working at a place that treats you
with dignity and
respect that's what we
want so go settle these debts pay it all
off this week man be done with it in
stay on the line we're going to hook you
up with Financial Peace University all
nine lessons and a year of every dollar
app the the premium one we're going to
hook you up okay thank you so much if
you don't use this fooy on you dude we
will come find you in me using my nice
language okay honor your mother pay off
your debts become a free man and go make
your legacy right this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian healthc Care
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly $1 billion do in
healthcare costs chm is an affordable
alternative to insurance that gives you
the freedom and empowers you to live out
your values and you can join at any time
so find out more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back this is the ramsy show 8825
5225 8825 5225 we're taking your calls
on money and life and work and
relationships I'm John deloney joined by
George camel listen if you are as
frustrated as I am about the economic
picture of the United States it's Matt
house and every time they keep releasing
more and more statistics about we're oh
trillions of dollars in student loan
debt and we're over a trillion dollars
in credit card debt and you just keep
thinking to
yourself how do people keep living like
this honestly we find a lot um either a
people don't care but more than that
people don't know they don't know any
different they've just been taught this
over and over and over and over again
got to care about your credit score got
to get a car payment you're always going
to have a mortgage all these things it's
just it's just the air we
breathe and instead of sitting at home
and screaming in yelling at the computer
screen or clenching your fist so tight
when you drive you're going to snap your
steering wheel in half there is
something you can do for your neighbors
that cost you no dollars nothing it cost
you about 10 seconds of your time and
you might roll your eyes and think this
is cheesy but if you like or subscribe
to the show if you follow us on
Instagram or on Tik Tok or on all the
social media platforms God help us all
if you subscribe to the show on YouTube
here's what it does it puts the show up
in the algorithm so when somebody types
how do I improve my credit score a video
of Dave Ramsey or George camel or Jade
warshaw talking about how ridiculous the
credit score scam is or should I take
out loans for my kid to go to college
and Jade warshaw or George campel or
Rachel Cruz or Dave will pop up how do I
save my marriage how do I talk to my
spouse about money a video from me and
George might pop up it's free you don't
have to do anything and it get begins to
circulate this information into the um
social media world and it gets this
information in front people we're
bombarded by millions of people reaching
out saying we saw you on YouTube we saw
you on some social media platform and
it's because folks like you who like And
subscribe to the show it's a simple way
to dump to dump this stuff into the the
public sphere and it cost you nothing
you don't have to buy anything so help
us out um and help out more importantly
your neighbor by sharing the show
leaving a review subscribing all the
things all right let's run out to Tulsa
Oklahoma and talk to Sky what's up
Sky I see what I did there that was kind
of funny what's up Sky hey how we doing
Sky I'm good how are you good what's
happening yeah so I just wanted to call
in I'm wanting help with my plan to pay
off my debt faster and I was also
wondering if I should put Less in my
401k while doing so that's a brilliant
idea sky are you new to are you new to
Our
Gang uh
yeah awesome welcome welcome to the cult
George has the Kool-Aid for you let's do
it I got it so yeah what's causing you
to go hm maybe I should pause investing
for a little while well I listen I've
been listening to y'all uh for a little
bit now and I I've heard one episode
where you were telling them to stop
putting in so much in their 401K while
trying to pay off your debt and I
thought it was I thought it might have
been a good idea for me I'm putting in
5% right now what does that amount to
Dollars wise probably a month like
160 so if I told hey what if I gave you
an extra $2,000 to get rid of debt this
year would that help
you yeah yeah and you'd get out of debt
faster which gets you back to investing
faster and guess what when you're back
to investing you're not going to be
doing 5% you're going to Triple that up
to 15% right because you freed up
something called margin in your budget
by getting out of debt and freeing up
those payments so that's the Tactical
piece of it but there's also
psychological emotional piece which is
oh my gosh I'm missing out on the match
that's the one right I'm missing out on
investing been told that you got to
invest early why would you stop
investing everyone's going to tell me
I'm crazy everyone's broke everyone's in
debt up to their eyeballs wondering why
they can't get ahead and one of the
reasons is they're doing too many things
at once and they're not making Traction
in any of the
areas gotcha and so pausing for a short
time how soon will you be out of debt if
you
pause
uh probably way sooner um a few months
at least I have like I have 43 right now
43,000 and what do you
make I make my father is like 51 but I
probably take home I waitress as well so
alt together I probably take home 45 a
month so the goal for you is to go hey I
want to pay this off in two years is
that a good
goal yeah so basic math says that's
about 21,000 a year you have to pay
down so now we go all right how do I
find a little under $2,000 a month in
margin that might mean cutting expenses
cutting subscriptions increasing income
more waitressing all of that will help
you find that margin and as you pay off
debt you're going to free up payments
which increases the margin you're going
to throw at the next smallest debt using
the debt snowball and that really helps
that helped me pay off my 4,000 years
ago Sky when I made that goal and I went
all right I need 2,000 that's the magic
number how do I create $2,000 in margin
every month and then that was my next
goal was side hustles ubering lifting
Consulting freelancing eating Ling
Cuisines when they were on sale five for
$10 dollars so that I wouldn't be
tempted to go out to eat because I had
food at home it's those kinds of micro
decisions that add up to that big
margin
gotcha so I've been like paying off my
lowest account debt first because it's
the highest interest do you think that's
the best plan to do is that the snowball
basically the debt snowball ignores
interest rates and it says hey just
attack the smallest balance with a
Vengeance make minimum payments on the
rest because that's going to give you
something called motivation progress
momentum gotcha so as you do that you'll
Freight a payment you'll take that
payment you freed it up apply to the
next debt and the next debt and I'm
going to gift you one year of Financial
Peace University because this walks you
through it beautifully and it helps
dispel so many of the myths out there
that might be holding you back while
also motivating you to make some
progress so hang on the line we'll gift
you one ear of that Sky to give you all
the info you need from our friends John
Dave Rachel and myself all right let's
run out to Chico and talk to
Andrew where is we lost Andrew oh we
just lost Andrew all right let's roll
out to Atlanta and talk to John what's
up
John hey good afternoon how are you
great how are you I'm trying to get off
speaker phone here give me a sec on
phone is smarter there we
go I'm trying I'm trying to be a good
Christian man my my daughter my uner
started meute to Denver earlier this
year and I've been having to monthly
kind of help her out to make her in
meets okay can I pause real quick can I
pause real quick sure y let's change
your language you don't have to do
anything you've chosen to send her money
and fund whatever World she's living in
um correct I'm helping fund her
lifestyle okay and cool I'm reaching a
point where I'm I'm I fear I know that
personally when I was in my mid 20s I
was going nowhere and I was in debt and
I chose to change my life and I went
back to school and then I had a really
successful career after that and now
it's 63 I've been able to retire really
based on Concepts that Dave preaches
okay um but it's hard as a father to go
you know what I know after she pays rent
the end of this week she doesn't have
money for food for the rest of the week
and how old is she I start feeling
guilty but I feel like I'm enabling her
at the same time there you go so um I
want you to like tattoo this sentence on
your chest and I didn't didn't originate
with me I think it originated with Berne
Brown but um it it comes from the some
somebody smarter than me when you're
doing the right thing
relationally and the right thing right
now is not to fund
somebody's um further spiraling into the
ground I want you to choose guilt over
resentment every
time okay I'm I'm writing this down
choose guilt over resentment just
because it you feel quote unquote bad
doesn't mean it's not the right thing
just because you feel guilty when she
calls and says but Dad she's a grownup
she's choosing the job she has she's
choosing the apartment she lives in
she's choosing the state she lives she's
making a bunch of adult choices and you
feel guilty by not funding that but
here's what's happening every time she
texts you you're starting to resent it a
little bit you don't like her being an
you don't like being her ATM machine you
don't like the fact that you're
projecting out cuz you know 55 year olds
and 60-year-olds who had everything paid
for and then suddenly it got cut off and
you flew past them in the marketplace
didn't you yes yes and so you're
starting to feel the resentment build
the honorable thing here I think is to
have a hard conversation with her and
say you got three months left but Dad
you you got three months left as my
friend Dr Henry Cloud says she needs
some problems like rent like um
insurance payments she's going to have
to learn to step stand up on her own you
can scaffold for a while but she's going
to have to become an
adult and adult adulting is hard this is
the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi /
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey George Kimel has a brand new book
coming out in January called Breaking
Free from broke pre-order today for only
20 bucks and get a $100 in free bonus
items including some special childhood
drawings George I'm just kidding you get
George's newest talk show me the money
exclusive access to Online private event
and Q&A with George I heard you're going
to be dancing at that event we don't
know oh it's a secret I like that uh
audio book ebook everything plus every
book includes a special offer to receive
three months of the pre prium version of
every dollar for free George give me a
quick synopsis you have to pitch this
book in an elevator the financial system
is designed to keep us broke it's not
all our fault but it's our
responsibility to take action not by our
hand but in our lap exactly and you can
Rise Above This broken system and opt
out completely and live a life with more
freedom options margin and joy so that's
it as what it appears is that the you
know we looked last year during the
holiday spending and we saw holiday
spending went up a little bit and credit
cards went up too credit card balances
oh yeah well you hit a trillion John and
so it looked as though oh people aren't
using credit cards for groceries they're
looking at it to prop up a lifestyle and
it looks like we are that part is coming
to an end or people are starting to go
uhoh well it's compounding because now
auto loan debt is at an all-time high
surpassing student loans the student
loan debacle still hasn't been solved
the housing Market's out of control
nobody's wanting to pay off a mortgage
cuz they have low interest rate our pets
heads are falling off we're taking out
helocs because we have equity in our
home and this is the solution to all of
our problems we're robbing our 401ks
left and right and then we're wondering
why uh the guy in the White House ruined
our life because it's all the inflation
John the eggs prices are out of control
or we could go I'm going to take control
of that guy in the mirror and he's going
to get on a budget and he's going to get
out of debt and he's going to change his
family tree and it's in my control and
my power that agency is like a
superpower John it feels so good to just
not have to wait for someone else to try
to fix your life I remember um Joo and I
were doing an event together the the
Navy SEAL Flex by the way but he was
talking about hey back in the end you
know I'll say the Middle Ages you
finished a war not when your tour was
over but when the war was over and
people left their family particularly
men would leave their families and go
fight and they came back when it was
over which might be years right it might
be a long time and I think think about
the sacrifices made so that my family
would be okay so my family's land it's
been in my family for however many
hundreds or thousands of years would
remain in our like I'm going to go away
and do whatever I have to do
and when I fast forward to now and
people are like well I don't want to
take a second job or a third job because
there's Little League games and because
my shows are like it becomes we have to
we have to put ourselves in a historical
perspective and say yep you might lose
some memories for 2 or three years and
you free everybody right and your book
is a road map
to here's a modern day heading out for
war to get off this system and to
reclaim your life right reclaim margin
reclaim peace and if you do it for two
three four years um and you don't owe
anybody anything your kids don't know
that kind of piece right your marriage
doesn't know that kind of piece well
then there's a generational ripple
effect right because you took care of
your family and you got to take care of
your kids your kids got to take of their
their kids you got to leave an
inheritance leave a legacy and so that
the book unpacks in the first twoth
thirds just how disgusting the system is
to make you want to take a shower it'll
give you the ick enough to go I'm going
to try to cut up that credit card once
and for all I guess I don't need it
guess I don't need to keep up my credit
score guess I am going to pay my student
loans off because there's no white night
coming in on the on the horse to save me
yeah those kinds of decisions I think is
what people need going into next year as
they go my life didn't change last year
because of some guy in the white house
or because of the housing market I'm
going to make some changes and so this
book lays out how I did it how I went
from broke to millionaire how I broke
free from the system and how I've seen
so many people stand on our debt free
stage and say the same exact thing well
dude I'm I'm proud of you thanks for
putting this out into the world into a
world that desperately needs it and I
try to do do it with humor as I do John
and lots of research you know me yeah I
got to have fun while I'm doing it I
trust the research part the humor part I
there's a poison reference in there that
was just just for you so see if you can
spot it I would have preferred a John
deloney reference but that's cool go to
Ramy solutions.com
sstore it's 20 bucks go ahead and get on
the pre-order list right now let's go
out to New Hampshire and talk to Annie
what's up
Annie Hi how are you we're doing all
right how are
you good thanks thanks for taking my
call you got it what's
up um well I found myself um it's been a
hard few years I have four kids and I'm
going through a really bad divorce and
um I'm sorry I ose it's okay he left
like
completely and um I don't know where he
is I am getting child support in alimony
but I was a stay-at-home mom I'm 35
years old I have about 20 grand in
student long debt and I'm I'm not sure
where to start um I have a 2 and 1/2
year-old and I'm home with her right now
but um so how um are your other kids in
school yeah I have three kids in school
they 11 10 and seven yeah so you have a
lot going on um what what question can I
help you with today so question it's
like I I mean I did three and a half
years of college okay but it was like a
theater communications degree okay
should I finish my degree or should I I
mean should I focus on like working with
my child at like a preschool and just
budgeting and is do you have enough is
your does your alimony is it is it um
does your alimony and child support is
it certified by by a
courtroom yes okay so the the divorce is
final um in March it'll be final okay
but you're but the payments have been
locked in yes okay it's not just some
agreement that your husband just sent a
check that income every
month um it's about
6,100 okay and that's enough to cover
all the bills and
more yeah well he is covering all the
house bills right now um I would have
had higher Alam money
if um he wasn't doing that does that
make sense yeah yeah yeah what other
debt do you have outside of the 20,000
in student
loans maybe like 30 Grand in credit card
Bett okay and how much money do you have
in the
bank uh maybe
like
six 6,000 okay great so what we're going
to do is focus on this debt payoff
because that's going to give you some
breathing room here if you free up those
payments that's going to give you at
least a few hundred bucks extra every
single month
correct yes and then that'll help us
build a fully funded emergency fund I
want you to have six months of
expenses so add up what a monthly
expenses are to run your house and then
multiply that by six that's going to be
your next goal after we get rid of this
debt okay and then we're going to focus
on do we go back to work what do we do
with child care and focus on those
decisions after that but I think you're
going to have to go back to work to get
this stuff back
right I mean to get this debt paid off
how much money do you have left over to
throw at debt each
month uh so this is kind of crazy I I
just I let him handle all the finan
starting today you handle it and we're
going to help you with that yeah we're
going to hook you up with a whole bunch
of stuff but you're going to have to use
these tools here's what you need right
now more than anything a
plan yes because you've been spinning
out for a long time haven't you your
whole world blew up right yep
yeah so we're going to hook you up with
a bunch of resources including a
financial coach that will help you build
a budget from the floor up okay cuz all
the stuff's new you've been letting
somebody do this we're going to get you
taken care of but I want you to follow
this and listen this is real important
you had four kids and the picture of
your life that you had mapped out for
the next probably almost two decades was
to be a stay-at-home mom that world is
probably over that picture that's okay
it's just going to be very different
you're going to have to grieve what was
and then you're going to have to just
build a new picture and now you're going
to be a working single mom with four
kids it's going to be busy it's going to
be chaotic and right we're going to give
you some tools and you're going to use
some resources in your community and
you're going to knock this thing out of
the park okay okay we believe in you do
you believe in
you yeah and you know what's so awesome
my kids have have been we've been
listening to you guys all weekend and my
son who's 11 and goes mom on are you
call in call in call in well I'm glad
you did cuz we got you all right I'm
going to send you building a non-anxious
life we're going to send you FPU we're
going to send you every dollar for a
year and some time a couple of sessions
with a financial coach we've got you
call anytime we're so sorry this
happened it's the first hour in the
books here on the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
what's going on live from the
headquarters of ramsy solutions it's the
ramsy show where we help people build
wealth get out of debt find and do work
they love
and actually learn how to be in
relationships with one another I'm John
deloney joined by my good friend George
camel and we're taking your calls on
money life work relationships all of it
5225 8825
5225 let's go out to the Toom to Tom in
poror Peoria
Illinois what's up Tom hey guys thanks
for taking my call just had a quick
question for you what's up so my son is
in fifth grade and he's on the
basketball team he plays for the fifth
sixth and seventh grade team and also
the eighth grade team dude is he a stud
or is it a teeny tiny school um not to
Bo but he is he's pretty good um he
plays on the Travel team as well but um
for for his school team um they're
trying to buy sweatpants and a hoodie
for all the kids so that way when they
go to home games and away games they
look uniform you know as a as a team um
some parents are not able to
afford um the sweatpants okay and so the
the total amount is just under $1,400
for 21 sets of sweatpants and
sweatshirts um they're about $900 short
my wife and I are in baby steps 4
through six and we were just wondering I
was W your guys's opinion is it okay for
us to go ahead and just pay that
difference uh I would okay if we can
afford it um George you can win on the
money side but and and I would do it in
a way that just says an anonymous donor
came through exactly and um I wouldn't
want to become like I'm the parent who
but a or just let the coach say hey we
were able to get the money together it's
awesome right and that can be a
conversation between you and your son
when he's a little bit older and that'd
be cool what generosity looks like but
um yeah I would what do you think George
yeah I was going to include that exact
caveat is just do it in a way that
doesn't feel like hey guys I got this
one Tom's got this which is a very nice
thing to do how have you guys currently
raised those funds the other 500 bucks
uh the school's trying to do they call
it a hot shot it's just a a raffle
during the halftime of the the games and
so they've raised you know 30 bucks here
40 bucks here a couple other parents
have been able to to donate you know
maybe 4060
$80 but so you're going to finish this
off with $ 900 bucks in the
raffle um because it's already Anonymous
right correct and you might win the
raffle you'll win like a gift basket
what is this uh you you get to shoot
four shots during halftime and if you if
you make a shot you get something from
the concession span I hope that's you
Tom well and hey Tom so one of the
things that is um I I learned from a
group of college students so this group
of college students moved into a
low-income part of the community not to
save the
community but to become a
neighbor and these Co it's it was one of
the greatest privileges of my life
working with college students who were
so brilliant at solving some of these
problems that adults over complicate but
here's what they did and it was magic
they lived in an area where people
couldn't afford Christmas presents for
their kids and so what they did or
multiple Christmas presents
what they did was they offered people
opportunities to basically earn some
sort of credit clean up the park come
help us with some of our our weekly
meals because they would serve all the
kids in the neighborhood just a free
meal right okay and what they allowed
the parents to do is to retain their
dignity they may not have 20 bucks but
they sure had half an hour on a Saturday
to go clean up the park and that
translated into a toy cu the kids did a
great the college students did a great
job raising funds to buy some of these
toys but the thing that they were helped
Preserve in those neighborhood parents
was their
dignity okay they got to work towards a
thing these gifts even though it wasn't
a money exchange it was a time exchange
it was an expertise exchange it was a
support exchange and so I say all that
to say it may be that you can have time
this this may be time prohibitive but
maybe you've got time to set up one more
thing at a local church or a local
something or other and all the parents
who come and help hey guys I think we
have an opportunity to raise a little
bit more money but we're going to all
clean the church building at this local
church and they're going to kick in some
money and then look at that they kicked
in
$900 okay right and so the parents might
not have the money but they might have
the time and any way that's something I
always keep in mind any way I can
preserve somebody's dignity in doing
something like this and when I say to
preserve their dignity they have an
opportunity to work forward towards
something put some skin in the game even
though that skin may not be money that
skin might be time skin might be again
expertise it might be they showed up to
help um even 20 minutes 30 minutes
between my three jobs I can show up and
do 15 minutes worth of whatever anything
counts and then they are able to smile
when those when their kids get that that
tracksuit they don't hang their head as
much as yeah I participated in that too
again you may be running out of time
this may be this Saturday right and so I
would just go ahead and put the money
out there but anytime I can think long
term about this though is is including
as many people as possible in this I
always think is is is pretty great thing
to do 100% good call I kind of want some
of those matching sweats now John what
do you think me and you on the I've been
waiting for you to get us the matching
matching sweats me and you and Coleman
on the court well you and Coleman would
get bright white ones and I just am not
a white sweatsuit kind of guy we could
go kind of you could I feel like you'd
be uh all black all black I'll be on
that team really just me and you against
Coleman oh well some alley oops I don't
even know what that is all right do you
know hey hold on before we I know what
is it it's when they throw the ball
towards the guy who's already at the
basket and he dunks it right
James yes America if you're not watching
this if you're listening uh George just
Wikipedia at Ali oop I watched a lot of
Space Jam growing up John it's different
you are a Space Jam kind of guy there it
is but I do love that the generosity is
rarely uh something you regret you look
back on like shouldn't have given the
900 for those sweats right those
entitled little kids and so it's
something if if you have that on your
heart and you're in a financial place to
do it it's not setting you back and he
mentioned hey we're out of debt we don't
have this other you know goal on our our
monkey on our back we've got to get rid
of we did this so that we have the
margin to be generous exactly that's one
of the main reasons we encourage people
to follow these steps right and I I want
there is there is people who are in dire
poverty who need help right now right
and so I'm I'm not talking about that
that group of folks right I'm talking
about there's a difference between
walking into I'll just say waffle house
and you can pull one of the waiters
outside and just say hey thinking about
you here's $500 right the the dollar
amount would be the
same but if they if you go in with your
family and it's late and you are tired
and they do a great job and they make
some jokes the waiter does and make sure
your coffee is always
refilled and you pull them aside and you
say Hey you gave me a my family
something we haven't had in a long time
and that is focus time together and you
gave us peace
and I'm so grateful that you use your
talents I know you're exhausted I know
this probably isn't your career
destination right but you went out of
your way to honor and serve my family so
here's $500 the dollar amounts the same
but what I gave in that moment is
purpose and dignity that guy will that
guy that man or woman will walk 8T tall
right so it's finding ways to include
people in whenever possible sometimes
it's that's prohibit you can't do it but
if you can include people in the job
they're doing in a task they can support
you and then you bless them on top of
that it just it's a it's a gasoline on a
fire plus the
reward yeah just telling a story this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the ramsy show8 825 5225
I'm John deloney joined here by George
camel and we're taking your calls on
money work life relationships your
emotional mental health whatever you got
going on we got you 8825
5225 all right the question of the day
is brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly has local
service providers who can repair
maintain and improve your home their
network of experts offers top quality
work and customer service by trained
reliable service providers find the help
you need at neighborly domcom Ramsey
today today's question comes from Jackie
in Utah buckle up John my husband and I
are 47 years old and we're both
impulsive Spenders hey I recently came
across your podcast hold on can we start
right there yeah that's some
self-awareness I respect
that
okay I just James I know we got to go
through this question but I just got to
start right here we'll get there
eventually we are both impulsive
Spenders this is not a diagnostic label
like we are both 5
fo8 right just a fact so we can't reach
high things on our cabinets that would
be a logical sentence we are both
impulsive Spenders is not an empirical
fact the way this is laid out this is
actually my husband and I are 47 years
old and we both act like children there
it is we choose to be emotionally
immature with our spending habits and I
haven't read the rest of this I'm just
so sick of the way we have taken
adjectives and nouns and created them as
identity
verbs like we've created them I'm an
impulsive spender hey what can you do
what can you do no you're an impulsive
child all right I will not interrupt
again unless I have to go ahead thank
you for that John that was a very
helpful
redefinition here we go I recently came
across your podcast and we're both fired
up about getting out of debt I'm having
some real fear and doubt about myself
and whether if I'll be able to change my
habits and control my spending growing
up my family didn't have very much money
so I have always had a scarcity mind set
and I know that's where my impulse
spending comes from my husband isn't as
much of a spender as I am he came from a
financially stable home but they never
followed a budget the person I don't
trust to be able to make these Financial
changes is myself I've tried to change
in the past I get all fired up about
something and start down the road of
change but before long I revert back to
Old Habits I completely break trust with
myself and end up feeling ashamed and
defeated I desperately want to make
lasting changes with our finances but I
just don't have any faith in my ability
to do this how do I restore trust in
myself all right so first Jackie I
apologize for interrupting at the very
beginning and throwing a temper tantum
because you're calling it out I am
emotionally immature with my money and I
don't know what to do and I've got a lot
of compassion and sympathy for that
question so when somebody says how do I
restore trust in myself my instant
response is always be trustworthy be
trustworthy and so what does that mean
that means I have to begin to create a
world where
I do what I say I'm going to
do now sometimes we um Overlook uh we
step over dollars to pick up dimes when
it comes to stuff like this so for
instance I am a person who will always
follow the follow a budget how can I not
follow a budget if I spend money that's
not in the budget what do I have to have
to spend money I have to have my ATM
card I have to have cash cool if I take
away my ATM card if I take away cash if
I get rid of Amazon Prime then I cannot
do those things similar how can I stop
drinking Step One is get rid of the
alcohol get rid of the environments
where there's alcohol so how do I
restore trust in myself it's not this
White Knuckle Event where you're going
to be flexing I'm going to put in
significant hurdles in my way that make
it almost
impossible to fail when it comes to
gaining trust in myself like for me I
struggled with getting up and going out
to getting in the car letting the car
warm up driving across town to the gym
so seven or eight years ago I just
started slowly peace mealing the gym
together in my house now it's right
there right I've taken away all the
friction now when I say I'm going to
work out tomorrow I just go downstairs
and work out see like see what I'm
saying so yeah minim and there's been
Seasons when I gave my wife my ATM card
I was out of control I was an
emotionally immature spender I gave my
wife my at M card so I I literally
couldn't spend and then I had to sit
with that discomfort what do I want to
buy right now oh I don't really want to
buy anything I'm bored or I have a scary
meeting coming up or I don't really want
to go do this assignment or I have
administrative tasks I don't want to do
I had to deal with why I was feeling
those things I didn't have that
emotional that that little scrolling
thing that makes you feel so good that
dope of me dope of me dope of me I
didn't have that anymore right so how do
you restore trust become trustworthy
what do you think George yeah I'm with
that I was just thinking there's this
element of kind of making the bad habits
more difficult and making the good
habits easy and part of that is I'm
taking the apps off my home screen and
putting just every dollar there so
anytime I open my phone I see every
dollar it's a reminder I'm going to put
the every dollar sticker on my debit
card so that I'm reminded to go check
the app to make sure I have the money
and make sure I budget for it it's
things like that they may sound silly it
might seem silly to other people but if
it keeps you on track if that calendar
where you have the red X because you did
one more day of budgeting and you
tracked it that's a win you don't want
to break the chain now that stuff
matters psychologically and so I don't
know what that is for our friend Jackie
but she's got to figure out the root of
that and where she stumbling and if that
is Amazon we're taking out our debit
card information we are deleting it we
are making it difficult blocking that
website on our computer whatever we have
to do in order to get those good habits
in place I I can't stress that enough
that we over intellectualize Behavior
change sometimes and
um
sit down with your husband and say hey
it's really really important to me that
every week we do a budget together every
Sunday night can we just put this on the
calendar that we don't ever miss this
this is so important to me it helps me
feel safe and I'm trying to change my
life I want to change our tree I want to
change everything about our world will
you just have this budget meeting with
me on Sundays right what husband's going
to say no to that and afterwards we get
to watch our favorite show and we can't
do that until we have the budget meeting
yes or if you want to more adventurous
than than watch a show but we we'll get
we'll do things together after that
right but it's it's about bringing
people together and good for you Jackie
good for you uh this kind of change is
hard but also wow and by the way
changing a scarcity mindset um begin to
begin to keep a gratitude Journal write
down five things a day that start with I
am grateful for and begin to tip well
scarcity mindset is cannot be in um in
the presence of that's right it it
Withers and dies on its own little
thorny vine when you are in generous
right um because then you realize oh I
gave this kid this guy I over tipped
this person because they were so
wonderful I gave them their light bill
their water bill for the month and that
means I got to make lunch for the next
two days it's that exchange is almost
always worth it right always always so
good for you Jackie great great question
um we're going to run out of time to
take a call let's talk about um let's
run here on Jade's new book oh yes our
friend Jade warshaw has got a brand new
quick read it's her first one ever
coming out on December 5th called
money's not a math problem and you can
pre-order today for just 10 bucks you'll
also get access to a live online Q&A
with Jade and in this quick read jayon
covers the five Lies We tend to believe
about budgeting the right budgets the
best budgets they set people free to
accomplish their money goals with
control and confidence and Dave has been
saying for decades personal finance is
20% head knowledge it's 80% behavior and
that's what this book tackles this quick
read is not just about the numbers it's
about your mindset and your behavior in
there Jade's going to share her story
about her uh and her husband Sam how
they paid off
$460,000 in debt including 280k of
student loans with uh combating these
five lies and included in the book is a
special offer to get three months of the
premium version of every dollar totally
free for new users only so go check it
out today at ramsy solutions.com
store while you're there you'll notice
we've got the Cyber Monday sale popping
off John with tons of incredible deals
mean you could really stock up I don't
know is it going to be a very ramsy
Christmas under the tree for you guys
who knows I hope so maybe if you're
tired of going into your kids's bedroom
and you're like just walking through
family Christmases and there's just
discarded stuff stuff just Jun junk the
toy that instantly broke yeah or just a
dumb that book looks it needed D
batteries John we don't have enough D
batteries vampire love story book what
if this year you bought presents that
actually had the potential to teach in a
fun way and change people's lives go
ramsy solutions.com
store we'll be right
[Music]
back
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netw weite
gave us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for Ramsay and it will make
a difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at nets.com Ramsey that's
netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsy Showp
8825 5225 let's go out to Richmond
Virginia and talk to the LV what's up
Liv hey how are you guys thank you for
taking my call you bet thanks for
calling what's up okay so my question is
like with the amount of debt that I'm
facing should I just go ahead and start
paying my debt off or start the first
step of the baby steps I'm 25 and I have
about like I want to say about $31,000
worth of debt um 20,000 of that is to
the car that I just bought and then um
4,000 of that is towards a credit card
that I actually um sorry to admit I had
to set a payment plan up for because I
didn't want to go like judgment or
anything like that and I kind of like
made a lot of mistakes just being young
and I'm like in a process of my life
right now just trying to clean it up but
I work two jobs and I'm still living
paycheck to paycheck and I'm just trying
to figure it out right now well thank
you for your honesty we're not we're not
here to judge you or beat you up we want
to help you with a plan that actually
works cuz so far Liv's plan ain't
cutting it yeah I remember being there I
was the same way I think I was 23 when I
got on this plan and I had 4 $4,000 in
Consumer Debt so I remember that feeling
going like is this it this is this like
American Dream thing that I've been
chasing down my entire you know heading
into my adult life so we want to help
you here what's your income from these
two jobs um so from my first job um I
would say a month um monthly growth I
make about 4,000 and then my second job
it's part-time I probably make about
700 gross yeah a month
yeah okay so you're making over well
over 50k and you've got 31 in debt this
is a a simple math equation of how do we
pay this off very quickly to get rid of
this debt in let's say 18 months or two
years does that sound about about right
yeah and so it's going to start with
baby step one there's a reason why these
baby steps work you got to do them in
order with focused intensity because
when we try to do too many things at
once we tend to get nothing done okay so
how much money do you have in the bank
right now um not a lot cuz I'm a really
bad spender just like the the email just
admitted like and I'm not going to say
impulsive I'm an irresponsible spender
hey hey look at that Liv you're gonna be
out of debt in no time you know why
because you take responsibility that's
incredible good for you so where are you
tending to spend
money um uh fast food and recreational
if you guys know what I mean oh okay
okay well how about this can you put
some restrictions in place to where you
go I'm going straight from work to home
because I've got food at home yes and
even when I it's inconvenient and I feel
late oh remember I meal prep Sunday I
already prepped all the chicken and rice
and broccoli for the week so I don't
really have an excuse to go eat out okay
is that part of it is just
convenience yeah definitely um
definitely I've stopped eating out as
much because I was eating out it came up
to roughly about 550 a month when you
added it up yeah yeah that will
definitely give you some sticker shock
cuz people think well I probably spend
you know 150 bucks on eating out and
then you actually go add up your bank
statement and you go oh it was more like
550 okay yeah we were in the ballpark so
that's part one is really getting the
spending under control and part two is
can we increase income even more and
when you do that you'll create something
called margin in your budget when you
learn how to spend less and make more
and that's going to help you pay off
this debt really
quickly okay um so that's what I was
also wondering if I picked up a third
job with that be branding myself out or
am I just thinking lazy I don't know
that I like those options as you're
super out or options do I want diarrhea
or to throw up how about neither of
those let's pick let's pick two
different yeah look at it as okay I can
get four months of my life back if I
pick up a few more hours because I'll be
out a debt faster and I can quit the
side jobs faster what job what are your
jobs that you that you do right now okay
I'm an office admin for a pool company
here in Virginia and then part I work at
an an adult novelty shop okay what is
your um what is your your pool job pay
you um about $15 an hour and my second
job is $12 an hour so I drove by the
other day in rural Tennessee and there
was a sign that said McDonald's was
hiring for 20 bucks an
hour yeah I would do it yeah what is it
about the pool job is that is that the
highest job making 15 bucks an hour
um honestly it's my first quote unquote
big girl job and I've never honestly
been paid as much so yeah this is like
the first job that I've been paid like
this much ever okay so I'm I want you to
hang on the line I'm going to send you a
couple of things we're gon to send you
our friend Ken Coleman's book from
paycheck to
purpose okay you're worth more
financially than you think and since
this is the first time and you may not
have um family members that make a lot
of money or make more than 15 bucks an
hour this makes you feel like a a
million bucks to you um I want you to
know that if you're if you're the kind
of person who's working two jobs and
willing to take on a third one you're
the kind of person I went working for me
that tells me you got a good work ethic
that means you're worth more than $15 an
hour the second thing is um we're going
to send you his get clear assessment
that will point you into into a
direction of not a job I don't want you
playing the oh they're going to pay me
25 cents more an hour this place will
pay me 75 cents more an hour and you go
from a restaurant to a car dealership to
a pool shop I want you start asking a
question you may have never asked
yourself ever which is what could I
actually do to contribute and make my
community a little bit better and help
people and make a great living at the
same time yeah and this assessment will
dig in and point you into a direction of
man maybe if I went and got certified in
this or I could go do this right now or
there's this this right down the street
or my buddy's dad works at this place it
can expand your horizons and make a
whole bunch more money you may not have
to take a third job is what we're saying
if you increase your dollar amounts
where you are now
okay I'm you said you were making $4,000
a month but based on $15 an hour it's
not tracking with me what's the $1 an
hour in a second
job um so my math may be off but just to
give you like a just straight up number
like um my last uh take-home pay was
about
$1,011 and that for every two weeks yeah
okay so you're we're we're talking 15 an
hour you said 4,000 originally and that
made me think you were making almost 50k
so that tells me you have way too much
car for your income this car is going to
have to
go yeah it's the first car that I ever
bought and it I was really struggling
without a car and I knew that I kind of
was maybe making a bad decision with
going with a 599 a month car note not in
Insurance one here's one way to tell if
you're focused on the monthly payment
you can't afford it if we're trying to
get the payment lower to afford it so
here's what I would do if I was in your
shoes cuz this this is going to help you
get some Financial Foundation if you
sold this car could you sell it for what
you paid for
it um yeah I've only had it for about
like eight months okay that would be my
goal what you need to do in the meantime
is save up some money to get you a
beater car to get you from A to B that's
all we're doing right now that might be
a $5,000 car that you can pay for in
cash that you found on Facebook
Marketplace you got it inspected at a
local mechanic they said it checks out
it'll get you a buy for two years and
Liv okay people made fun of me and
George for years and years and years for
what we
drove and you know what matters not at
all our wives still like us most most of
the time our kids like us they didn't
marry us for our money I'll tell you
that much they're depreciating assets
nobody
cares yeah no I agree it was just I was
going through such a hard time
previously before receiving this car
that I was like if I'm going to go get a
car and get a note I want to get
something that is close to what I like
but I kind of feel like I made a mistake
doing that it's okay hey I did the ex
exact same thing out of college I bought
the biggest dumbest truck I could find
and okay yeah because I deserve it I've
been driving this little crappy car I
deserve it it's just I fell into the
traps that George writes about in his
new book like I just fell for it just
hook line and sinker you deserve Freedom
left and that means driving this crappy
dumpy car that you paid cash for and it
doesn't have a $600 payment attached and
that helps you get rid of your credit
card debt once and for all helps you
build an emergency fund so that you can
be on this other side with no payments
money in the bank investing for the
future and now you can focus on a job
you actually want cuz you're not
desperate for that next
paycheck thank you guys so much does
that feel right hang on the line here
we'll hook you up we're going to get you
those things from Ken Coleman and we're
going to send you um a year of FPU
Financial Peace University I want you to
watch all the lessons watch them all
especially the one on wi spending that
me and John do that's right we tag team
back again a lesson on wise spanding
make sure you check that out this is the
ramsy
show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
this hour we're taking your calls about
money life relationships whatever's on
your mind whatever's keeping you up at
night we we want to talk about itle 8825
5225 all right let's go out to Gabe in
chitown Chicago Illinois what's up
Gabe hi thank you both for your time
today you got it man thanks for calling
what's up so my wife and I we are on
baby steps four five and six um and and
as you know we're currently living in
Chicago and we bought a condo last year
um super happy but now we're thinking
about moving to Florida look going to
grow our family wanted to get closer to
to to my parents and and her parents and
so we're moving to Florida and we're
unsure what to do with with our condo uh
does it make sense to sell it uh should
we run it because we've only had it for
about a year and a half um there has
been some some appraisal value to it but
but with agent fee that we're really not
sure what to do
here what are you going to do in Florida
are you going to buy a place
there not originally um our our hope is
to rent first to see if we like it um
but that we're we're not too sure yet
what if you sold the Chicago condo and
whatever you make from the proceeds you
may have to pay a little bit of capital
gains taxes that sounds it sounds like
and you just park that money while
renting for a year in Florida what would
the harm be
there no no harm at all um I I I there's
a slight increase in terms of the the
appraisal value so you know we we we're
trying to break even hopefully that
could happen we're unsure if if if
that's the right move but with us being
able to rent it it could make sense that
eventually down the line there could be
more more value in the place more equity
and and this it sounds great on paper
here's what the reality is napkin M you
live in Florida and the HVAC is busted
and now you're trying to deal with this
as a long-distance landlord with a
property you can't even see or deal with
and that part worries me because the
truth is if you're living in Florida you
wouldn't go out and buy a condo in
Chicago and so when you think of it in
the reverse uh when you reverse engineer
it you go yeah that doesn't make sense
this is a bad move we're going to take
the we're going to break even this is
not going to be a money-making scheme it
was never meant to be and renting this
place out may not be the best thing for
our financial future right now or let's
let's take the HVAC off the table cuz
that's when you can call an HVAC company
let's say you get tenants and they're
super trustworthy
and then the husband goes over to his
buddy's house and ends up in an
essential oils uh pyramid
scheme and then he watches a video on
all the mold in the house in Chicago and
then suddenly he develops a cough and he
calls you and says my house is covered
up in mold and we demand that you
remediate the whole house and I have to
have an a um a hotel for me and my wife
or rental covering medical costs as well
and you're like I need to go in there
and see it so now either you're hiring
somebody to come out and do that who has
a may have a vested interest in finding
mold or you got to get on a plan see how
dumb this is just sell the house and
I'll say this this is probably not the
best on paper again math is mostly a
psychology issue I mean I'm not math U
money is mostly a psychology issue I've
written a check on one house I went to
closing with several thousand dollars
because we were when you factored in
realer fees we were a little bit upside
down like three or 4,000 bucks I wrote a
check because the long to
long-term Financial benefit to me was in
my favor and so on paper like you lost
money on a house yep I did I lived in it
less than 12 months I wrote a check on
it and then I was able to transform my
family so I I mean I just that extra
baggage of having a house a bunch of
States over just doesn't seem worth it
to me the other option is could you live
in it six more months and hit that
two-year Mark yeah why do I want to move
all of a sudden
yeah there's there's I guess that's
another thing that's in our favor
there's no rush we once again want to
start a family we we want to get closer
to to our family uh but there's we're
both remote so we don't have to leave
right now uh we we can be patient great
but uh but yeah no no immediate rush I
I'd stick it out through the Chicago
winter and just go all right Florida's
on the other side but right now we're
going to hang tight and you can have a
baby in Chicago I found out they have
like hospitals there
well also tell you this my wife and I
had a bunch of plans she went to grad
school then I went to grad school then
she got her 10-year track job and then I
got my administrative job and we had
mapped it out and now we're going to
have a family and then we didn't get
pregnant and then another year would bu
and then another year went by and so the
best laid plans right I mean so you can
have all the plans in the world I
wouldn't rush something just to rush it
you know what I mean but I know you can
feel the bird like should we keep paying
on this house on this condo then if
we're going to sell it some day yeah
maybe but the number of times people
call the show and they say hey I was
doing something for 6 months and it's s
years later is regularly okay that's
just the way life works so I I I would
sell it when we moved and I wouldn't
rush the move if you just absolutely
don't have to and but that's just that's
just my two cents just two guys that's
right that's right all right let's go
out to Tampa where um Gabe really wants
to be living let's go out to Tampa and
talk to Kaden what's up
Kaden hey can you hear me yeah we got
you man what's up how's it going
partying dude what do you up
to oh well just calling in I have a
question for you guys so um I'm I just
turned 20 a few months ago I I just
moved to Tampa also a few months ago and
uh my first house here but I wanted to
get you guys' opinion on kind of um what
I should be doing with my money so I'm a
pretty high average income earner I I
guess I would say so I'm top 1% in uh
from my age group and I have a ton of
cash sitting in my bank accounts that I
don't know what to do and I don't have
really anyone in my life to talk to um
that are high income earners like in my
family are really even too too many
close friends so I'm wondering what you
guys think I should do with the money
because I'm kind of one of those guys
that saves everything that I can because
I've been listen to you guys for years
and uh I feel wasteful that's just
sitting in my bank account not doing
anything all right you got a
pin uh yeah all right venmo username at
George no I'm kidding I'm kidding uh
kayen job we can tell you all day what
you could do with the money I feel like
you have some goals in mind don't you do
you have a
home yeah so I just so my brother and I
run a business together so it's just me
and him living out here um and we just
bought a home uh about six months ago
together yeah so we liveed together in
here our mortgage is about 2,400 a month
and what we were renting last year was
3500 so are you both on the
deed uh well he just technically he is
oh boy no that's that's actually a good
thing I'm glad y'all didn't buy a house
together good so you rent from then I
can go get my own first house yeah
basically yeah how does how does the
equity work he has 100% of the equity in
this house we paid this house was only
about
360 okay just written room from his
brother okay you're just renting with
your brother yeah yeah we well we so we
run our business here so we have six
bedrooms and we have our own office
space and stuff but we run our business
together so but you have no financial
interest in this house let's say you
leave he doesn't have to sell he doesn't
have to give technically no yeah I just
want to make it real clear because you
may leave and go well I mean I've been
paying your rent we kind of rign this
thing together as a business so I feel
like I I got some skin in the game I
just i' we've seen too much where things
were supposed to go by the handshake
agreement and then life happened no no I
feel you we're we're twin brothers and
we so we run our business we 50-50 in
our in our business with equity and
everything so have youall written that
down somewhere yeah yeah we have a es
Corp and and everything as well which is
what I wanted to talk to you about so
like last year we put um 190,000 into
our 401 k um that's what we have in
savings we have about 200 to together so
about 990,000 each okay all right and
then um but it's we do it through I'm
sure you guys know what a Deferred
Compensation Plan is right so we have so
that's through our business as well um
so we have our own Flor 1K and then with
our business kind of matching it and um
basically it's like a pension plan if
that make sense that we contribute so
we're going to contribute again this
year another 200,000 into there way to
go what is your business man you'll just
print money you
hiring yeah no so uh basically I started
a business with him uh when we were 17
in high school like right after covid
but we basically just do Arbitrage so it
started with just reselling things
online flipping it on eBay Amazon um and
then kind of grew into doing more of
that as well as just Consulting and
stuff so there's people that wanted to
learn what we were doing have that and
it all kind of just kind of runs
together if you don't have any debt to
pay off my next goal would be to be a
homeowner and own an asset in that way
like your brother does and so that's
what I would be doing and you may want
to live there and you may want to get an
office instead of doing it out of the
house that's up to you guys but I want
to own my own place as my next financial
goal and continue to invest and also
spend some give some that's going to
help you avoid a flat tire with your
life hey that that's the second hour in
the books thanks for joining us right
here on the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
Solutions in nationville Tennessee it's
the ramsy show where we help people
build wealth get out of debt do work
that they actually contribute to and
they love and we help people create
incredible relationships I'm Jo I'm John
delone you don't even know my own name
joined by George camel and we're taking
your calls on money life emotional
mental health both of us have been
walking alongside hurting people trying
to figure out what's the next right step
for years and years and years and we're
live talking to real people going
through real challenging times 8 825
5225 that's
5225 let's go out to my hometown htown
and talk to Christopher what's up
Christopher hey how's it going we're
doing good man what's up uh pretty good
so I'm in a relationship right now uh
everything's going great and I'm
planning on proposing uh maybe in the
next two weeks all right dude
congratulations thank you so U there's a
little dilemma I guess so about I love I
love engagement dilemmas Bring It On All
right so um previous I was in a
relationship previously before the one
I'm in now and I was engaged to the uh
girl and she gave me back the engagement
ring oh don't do it don't do
it I was thinking about just using that
r no dude I just does your girlfriend
know about this past
engagement no oh boy okay number one
have that combo first oh no no no no no
no she knew I was in yeah she knew I was
engaged before yeah she so do you not
think she's going to her first question
is going to be
wait is that the ring
from I I know I just don't want to spend
extra money on it CU Chris Chris going
to a different the moment you slide that
ring on her finger her her finger will
catch
fire okay like it will just electrocute
her and then by proxy you'll end up dead
that's just how this that's how this
will work dude don't do this you're
going to pay you're going to lose your I
both butt cheeks when you resell this
ring you will lose your butt and that's
okay okay it's called it's called Uh uh
that sucks tax and just spend it dude do
not regift an engagement
ring okay all right it's just it's just
too much bad juju and I'm not very you
know I'm not that guy John I don't do
the whole uh you know AST astrology and
all this stuff and I'm like well I just
feel like there's too much sentimental
value tied up in this ring from a past
relationship that fell apart that didn't
work out you're going to be feeling that
emotionally she's going to be thinking
that in the back of her head and then
it's going to spark a giant fight and
you're going to have to get a new ring
anyways and you better hope that
relationship even survives that
fight I don't know how I don't think
either of JN and I's wives would react
kindly if that was the situation and I
think that would be my wife's first
question it just kills me to spend more
money but okay you know what's going to
kill you also your fiance when she finds
out that you got the got a ring except
she's gonna kill you for real what is
what's a new ring gonna
cost well I guess I'll probably get
another one for 2K to 3K does it have to
be a 3K
ring I think for to look decent I guess
I don't know man they've got some rings
out there these days on Etsy that are
gorgeous and they're not the you know a
full carrot real diamond it might be
mois andite or something but I think
it's more about the thoughtfulness
behind it versus and especially not
giving her a real diamond ring that was
meant for a real past
fiance okay take a fake ring any day
over that I'm just almost at the $50,000
Mark as savings and just to see that
I'll be going back you have 50,000 in
savings I have 48,000 almost at 50,000
Chris where are you calling
us
Chris what are you doing with your life
man future she's going to be can we go
on the vacation and you're like I almost
have 50,000 in savings woman leave me
alone but I had this coupon left over
from my last relationship I know let's
call My Ex's father-in-law he has a
bedroom we can rent out like for real
dude man okay I bite the bullet and get
that new ring and sell the old one for
what you can get for it and Hey listen
like this is just like a straight up
like I I grew up in Houston do you not
have some like buddies there that you
could have run this question by that
would have just knocked you upside the
head well well I do but they love to
spend money so I didn't really all right
that's fair that's fair that's I I
support that then thanks for calling two
Wise Guys and ask any woman that's also
a good indic ask I'm pretty sure a 99.9%
would say yeah don't do that hey I'm GNA
I'm going to do a litmus test there is
one woman on the front row in the studio
audience are we right okay she just two
thumbs up so and she's got a ring on her
finger so she's got experience yes so
thank you ma'am for that no matter what
don't oh jeez don't hey George this is
awesome um not only are we helping
people get out of debt we are now saving
lives and PR homicide yes we're doing it
preventing homicide was a stretch but I
like it I like where you were going with
it I if I'm sweating even thinking about
proposing to Whitney with a previous oh
my
gosh I I can't breathe John that's a lot
for me some let's um James can we take
another call
sure Dad said yes let's go out to Dusty
and Boise what's up
Dusty Hi how are you phenomenal what's
up okay my question is um just last week
for Thanksgiving my dad gifted my
husband and I um a house mortgage free
um so we are currently living in a yes
wow not even Christmas my dad gave me a
FaceTime wow so I know I know we were
balling our eyes like little babies so
it was pretty cool um but we're living
in a house right now we owe $200,000 on
it still um but we're wondering if we
should move into the mortgage free house
and rent this one out or if we should
sell this and with the profit we make
pay off our debt and then put the rest
away in an account that acrs over years
we don't know what to do at all I like
that plan because if you keep this
mortgage move into the mortgage free
house you're still in debt doesn't
really solve your debt
problem yes we have about $30,000 in
debt okay and what's your household
income um it's about so he is salary um
after taxes we bring home about $4,500 a
month okay now being mortgage free you
should be able to pay off this Consumer
Debt fairly quickly I imagine with no
mortgage
right yes so I would do crunch num ifed
as a rental you just hang I want toiv
off I don't like investment property
that has mortgages attached but that's
one option I think the the option that
will give you more freedom and more
peace right now would be to sell it and
move into this
home okay are there any tax implications
with moving into this home do that
instantly I'm so sorry say that one are
there tax implications of inheriting
this home while he's still
alive nope huhuh I would just want to
make sure of that because there's you
may have to pay the cap capital gains on
that and uh I would talk to a tax Pro
you can connect with one at Ramsey
solutions.com just to make sure your
eyes are dotted and te's are crossed on
this financial transaction and sometimes
gifts are incredible and they're
lifechanging and they're not what's best
for our family so make sure before you
just go running to move into this house
it's it works for you and your family
for a season um but yeah I'd sell my
house take the equity pay off all my
debts be completely free of everything
[Applause]
[Music]
in
this is the Ramsay showle 8825 5225 I'm
John delone joined by George camel let's
go out to Milwaukee and talk to Tony
Tony Tony what's up
Tony hey how are you so good exited how
are you good you I mean I'm you are as
joyful as we are what's
up well I'll see if my tone doesn't
change but uh oh no I don't think it's
too big of a deal but I do it's been
uh I've been like you know thinking
about it and all that so I thought give
you guys a c so here's the hey Tony do
me a huge favor talk directly into your
phone for me oh I um he was he was
telling me to do that can you hear me
now yes perfect okay cool um so here's
kind of the background so we got married
a
few months ago and we grew up in
different Financial philosophies my
parents were older than his and and
whatnot so he has some debt I don't have
any debt per se besides the
mortgage um so I have some savings so I
have two questions going on so one is a
money thing but another one is kind of
like a a career choice type of thing so
the first thing with the money
is um so I have money in the bank and I
could easily
pay for his debt and I know you guys
always say oh you guys are married you
know now your finances are together and
everything like that but I kind of have
like oh he had this before I don't want
to pay for it and then
it happens again and it just like it's a
whole big cycle type of thing so I was
kind of wondering like should I kind of
help him pay for it or
just uh let him deal with it how he
wants Tony why did you get
married why yeah because I wanted to I
mean I mean like why did you want to
what benefit was marriage going to bring
to you
um how is it going to enhance and
improve your
life um oh my gosh I didn't think you
guys I don't know that's throwing me
back CU you're
noty you're you're not answer you're not
asking a money
question you're not you think you are
but you're
not you're asking a marriage question
and the way you framed it and you can go
back and watch it on on YouTube whenever
it posts or listen to the podcast the
way you ask the question is very similar
to a caller we had in the first hour who
was concerned about her stepson getting
too much stuff from her new
husband you spoke about your new husband
as though you're his mom and you're
considering teaching him a
lesson oh and this is your husband for
better or worse sickness and in health
in good times and in bad
times he doesn't have a financial
trajectory separate and apart from your
financial
trajectory he doesn't have a life
separate and apart from your
life y'all opted in together in front of
your parents in front of God in front of
each other and said I do till death till
one of us
dies that means right or
die and so that starts at a bare minimum
with hey I got a whole bunch of money in
this account we're going to start on the
same Financial footing but deeper than
that
is the thought of you doing this again
and committing Financial infidelity
scares me so
bad will you take this class with me so
we can become on the same
page well what do you mean like
how uh well like I want us to be on the
same footing so I don't know that's what
I should do like help him out but he
doesn't want me to pay for his debt
which I totally get well here's what it
looks like Tony it's you guys setting
new goals together one of those goals is
how cool it would be to start this
marriage off completely debt free so our
goal is debt Freedom this is now our
money we're going to combine bank
accounts right now you're treating him
like you're the healthc care company and
he's coming in with a pre-existing
condition and you're like nope that's on
him he came into the marriage with that
I mean nobody wants to be treated like
that and by the way you talk to him as
though you're a parent um this weekend I
was out hunting with my son and I forgot
something out in the field and my son
was like no Dad here you can just use
mine and all he was trying to make me
feel
better and if during your courtship
while you were dating and then you know
in your early part of your marriage I'm
sure your husband's gotten loud and
clear that he married someone who's kind
of like his mom and so he's like no no
I'll take care of the Dead I I'll take
care of it Mom I got it I got it I got
it I got
it and sometimes people do that to
preserve peace
ke and so if you look out 10 years from
now and you could wave a magic wand
financially for your family what would
it look
like uh we're taking some trips we're
money happy you know having um money in
the bank and saving for retirement and
that sounds exactly like conversation
with my seven-year-old daughter be
specific 10 years from now what does
your financial picture look like some
unicorn some wolves with wings like be
specific what do you
want
um just having some money for retirement
and we can take some traveling for
experiences if I'm older so if kids are
in the picture um great and we don't
have to worry about any are you paying
are you paying for those Vacations or is
he paying for the
vacation uh we the ones that we've taken
we've split it like you pay for part of
it and then I pay for a part of it so
we've split it in the past that's what
me and George do when we go to
Chick-fil-A sometimes John even pays for
me which I think is very chivalrous
sometimes okay but you see what we're
saying Tony marriages are either growing
together or they're growing apart and if
you start to say well that's his debt
he's got to run his own race I'm going
to do my thing you're going to grow
apart you're running in two different
directions when you're both in the same
direction you're going to grow together
and you're going to have shared goals
shared common language around money and
that's going to not only grow your
finances and your wealth but it's going
to grow your relationship and that's
what we found time and time again when
people take that get over that big
hurdle of combining finances it's not
about well I don't trust him with money
it's about what are we building together
because what we can build separately is
fine what we can build together is
monumentally greater and you kept
mentioning retirement it sounds like
your Chief concern might be one of
safety and if you married somebody like
my wife did who's kind of immature and
silly and goofy and runs around and it's
kind of like ah it's all going to be
okay you may be looking down the road
and say hey I need to make sure that I
am preparing for our security right for
our retirement yeah I was blessed when
my wife brought me into that
conversation and it was something along
the lines of I'm So terrified We're not
gonna have anything with the way you
spend
money and I remember thinking not all
right I got to figure out this budget
thing with Dave Ramsey no no I remember
thinking I never want my wife to feel
terrified with
me and she wasn't in protection she
wasn't in a I'm always going to work
hard but she was in how I was not saving
money and how I still had debt so we
worked together and that's how we
changed stuff and now she's got more
security than she could have dreamt of
and I do too you see you see what I'm
saying like it's just it's just a matter
of working together if I send you the
financial peace course will you and him
watch it together and youall imagine a
future where you all work together not
apart I believe I would but I don't know
if he would I think if I really pushed
him to he would how about instead of
pushing him again like a parent you
invite him it would mean the world to
me I would feel loved and safe inside my
own home and inside my own new marriage
if you would watch these nine videos and
you can roll your eyes through all of
them you can just go oh my goodness this
is so ridiculous whatever but will you
just watch him with me please it' mean
the world to me invite him in and if he
says I ain't doing that then here's the
hard truth your marriage is on way
shakier ground than you imagine you all
need to deal with that cuz that's some
that's that's respect and dignity and
love that's not a money conversation
that's way deeper but invite them in
stay on the line we're going to hook you
up with a year of Financial Peace
University and the every dollar app that
you and your husband can do together
y'all can grow together like George said
and not apart this is the ramsy show
we'll be right
[Music]
back
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John delone
and it is one of my favorite days of the
year I'm not going to call it a holiday
but I do get a little pep in my step on
Cyber Monday and Ramsay's getting in on
it with our one-day Cyber Monday sale
and it's our lowest prices of the year
today only that's not a joke we don't
make stuff up that is truly the lowest
prices you're going to see on some
awesome gifts for your family and
friends as low as five bucks we got some
audio books starting at just $5 my
friend Dr John delon's new audio book
building a non-anxious life is 10 bucks
for the first time ever Financial Peace
University just $59.99 our lowest price
of the Year there we've got the 2024
Ramsey gold Planner on sale down to 40
bucks right now Rachel Cruz has got a
new Navy wallet and a new kids book on
sale I've got a new book called Breaking
Free from broke on pre-order Jade
warshaw's got a new quick read called
money's not a math problem everything is
there what are you waiting for just go
shop at ramsy solutions.com
store you can tell them George sent you
it won't matter you won't get an extra
deal but it'll make me feel good
actually you're really going to confuse
everybody hey George said to tell no
yeah you don't have to tell anyone it's
fine I did that the other day at the
grocery store Starbucks it didn't work
sent me sent me here in the cult
security all right let's go out to
Cincinnati Ohio and talk to Kathleen
what's up
Kathleen thank you for taking my call
first of all um both my husband and I
are retired we're totally debt-free
and the question that we have
is I hope you're still there question we
have we're listening intently okay the
question that we have is we're going to
have to put a new roof on the house
we've got our six months of
um oh emergency fund or whatever but
we're wondering do we need to take that
to pay for the roof or should we go
ahead and take a withdrawal from our
retirement he yeah what's the roof going
to cost oh between 20 and 25 and you're
sure that this is not covered in any way
shape or form oh yeah no we've been in
the house since 99 or since 03 so it's
over 20 years old okay so it's time is
this how how much of an emergency is
this is it falling in do we need to do
this
tomorrow well no we got to do it within
the by next year for sure okay and do
you have the money right now in the
emergency fund yes okay I'm just going
to use that and if you want to build a
little savings account until the roof is
there start doing that are you guys in a
good Financial spot to do
that oh I I guess we could it's just
that we feel uncomfortable draining the
emergency fund just what if a washer
refrigerator whatever has to go okay
well you're you're retired so you can
pull from your retirement accounts do
you guys have a giant Nest Egg where
this would barely touch it wouldn't make
a dent um unfortunately no we're very
simple um got like I think 350,000 in
retirement um our savings that's about
it we get what's in what's in the a year
we've got 20 grand in in the um
emergency fund okay and our security is
around 50 Grand okay so are you guys
just making money from Social Security
you're not touching the retirement
account sorry you broke up with us
Kathleen are you still with us yes okay
exactly so just Social Security you
haven't touched the retirement account
but there's only 350k in there right and
you guys are How old uh 66 okay so you
could have a nice long retirement and I
want to protect that Nest Egg as much as
we can so I would rather tap into the
emergency fund and then replenish it
versus drain 10% of my entire Nest Egg
to cover this one
repair okay we were that's what we were
thinking but wanted to can I thr third
option and John has a third option which
is probably even better can I throw well
it may not be better just another thing
to consider um my mom is 73 74 recently
retired from her job as a professor
and she is looking for a part-time
job and it might be it'll be it'll be
adjacent so it might be editing
dissertations or um editing manuscripts
or she's an extraordinary editor who
knows what she going to be doing but is
there a possibility that your husband is
retired um or you you'll head back and
take two part-time jobs and with just
the just the intent of we're going to
earn this money um we can work through
the holiday season we can work into the
fall it's going to be freezing cold
anyway so we're in Ohio so we need to be
inside anyway we're just going to make
some extra money and we're just going to
do this together and we're not going to
do anything strenuous and we're gonna
earn this money and pay the roof with
cash well yeah that's an
option you know s too John wants me to
go to work boo no I totally get
it I do Medicare insurance so I'm in the
annual enrollment period right now okay
so I'm going going nuts but I will have
you know some extra leeway come January
because that's when they pay us okay so
you know that that will that will help
um my husband is getting ready we see an
orthopedic surgeon for back
surgery so he's not going to be in a
position to do that okay well just
something to consider if um if money's
tight to soften the blow yeah there you
go and maybe you're not draining the
entire emergency fund but maybe you can
earn $10,000 between the two of you over
the next 6 months and um and that's
working at Home Depot that's working
online that is finding some sort of
part-time gig or whatever that looks
like and maybe you're only pulling
$10,000 from your emergency fund and the
other 10,000 you're paying with cash for
the roof whatever that looks like but
that's just a third option yeah just
just an idea but it's better than going
into debt either of these options
absolutely all right let's go out to
Sabrina in Honolulu hey Sabrina
aloha aloha what's
up hi um what's up the cost of living
yeah for real hey how can we
help well um I have been blessed to be
able to go to the Financial Peace
University classes and thankfully I am
debt-free but I want to know how I I
have a lot of family and friends and
even church members I'm a leader in the
church and I I just want to know how I
can help
them do the same as I without I mean I
don't have the means to buy everybody
else my naturop University uh um you
know uh class so how would I be able to
help um people in my life to also become
debt free and get this you know fulfill
the baby
steps hello yeah we're here oh okay yeah
I'm just thinking through it that I mean
that's a fascinating question
um I think the first thing I would do
is invite them into a conversation in
your home and the the struggle is some
people have no interest in getting out
of debt they don't even understand a
world outside of a credit score and a
car payment and a mortgage that that
that's not something that's even
occurred to them and so sometimes you're
looking at people being like hey you
want to move to Mars and they're just
like no I'm good here on Earth and so
sometimes they're going to see the fruit
in your life over the next few years and
they're going to say why are you always
smiling Sabrina um why do you tip so
generously like cuz I can right so
that's number one um but I'd invite them
over to your house and ask them if
they're interested and with the limited
resources you have you might be able to
talk them through it Point them to the
show um decide you're going to serve as
a reference point and if you hang on the
line here we can put you in touch with
our Financial Peace University team that
actually has a division that that works
with churches and um where you could
start a class at your local church and
teach your family members and your local
um parishioners uh people who attend
your church if they're interested George
what do you think yeah I think your your
life is the best kind of financial
testimony to get people excited about it
but John's right in that they need to
want to make a change and you can be
there for them when that happens and you
know it doesn't have to be Financial
Peace University like John said there's
so we pretty much do everything for free
if you want to grab a bunch of books The
Total Money Makeover is on sale right
now for for just 10 bucks you could get
you know 10 of those maybe start a book
study at the house and say hey I've got
financial goals for next year I know you
guys probably do too let's all get
together and just encourage each other
and just kind of create this little
community of people who are growing yeah
when I was in my early 20s Sabrina um I
didn't have money to pay for it every
but and I had a group of people that I
cared about so I bought everybody a copy
of Total Money Makeover and I got online
and printed off the free budget template
and I put it in a binder so everybody
for Christmas got a binder full of 12 um
monthly budgets and got a copy of Total
Money Makeover and that was I I didn't
have enough money for everybody um but
that's what I bought and that's the best
I could do and then have been available
for conversations and questions ever
since and so um but thank you so much
for your heart for for feeling this
sense of freedom and this sense of light
and you want everyone in your life to
share in it with you what a generous
generous Spirit hang on the line and
Austin can direct you to our FPU team
this is the Ramsey Show we'll be right
back
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show today's
scripture is from Proverbs
16:16 how much better to get wisdom than
gold to get insight rather than
silver the great Muhammad Ali said a man
who views the world at 50 as he did at
20 has wasted 30 years of his life what
an amazing amazing athlete and a great
quote I love it I love it all right
let's uh real quick George let's talk
about this every dollar app we talk
about it a lot on the show and people
are going what do they keep mentioning
this every dollar thing for what is that
it's the greatest budgeting app on
planet Earth that's one way to put it
and I would agree if you want to manage
money the ramsy way you can go download
every dollar on your iOS device Android
or you can access it online as well and
you can start for free and what it does
it immediately shows you where you stand
with your money it's going to help you
get organized it's going to help you
personalize your budget help you stop
overspending and save more money and if
you're new to every dollar we've got uh
some new features like a long-term
Financial road map where you can track
your net worth your debt free date your
retirement date your baby step progress
and more we're going to proactively
coach you to build wealth and reach your
goals all from the palm of your hand Go
download the free every dooll app for
IOS and Android or go to everydollar.com
to get started all right let's go out to
Washington DC and talk to the great will
hey Will what's up man hey how we doing
today outstanding how are you good man
doing amazing hey I just wanted to call
in and uh thank you guys for um giving
away uh Financial priest and um every
dollar for vets I was listening to the
show right before Veterans Day and um
I'm a Marine Corp reservist I've been in
for 20 years and um I went in put my
name in the Hat to get one of those um
the every dollar signed up and me and my
wife down and uh we put our budget back
together uh we're currently working
through baby step four and uh we started
uh getting the transactions coming in
every um couple days later and we're
going through all the um spending and um
found out that there was a bunch of uber
charges and Chipotle on the um on our
account and we didn't know what it was
did George Campbell steal your a credit
card my bad dude I think yeah I think
that's a George Campbell move right
there that dude loves Chipotle and
Uber and we don't so so we knew it
wasn't ours that's one way to find out
about 200 bucks um somebody had uh
gotten some free rids and some free
chipot Chipotle on us oh so is your card
stolen huh yep it was stolen um it's the
card
number yep card number yep man I'm sorry
to hear
that well it also showed us that we were
spending about ,000 doll on eat out so
you were robbing yourself right
there I was wondering how to get through
baby step four and I think we found it
we were eating our retirement wow what a
great what a Great Awakening we are
eating our
retirement yep how do we get to 15% well
for starters we got to look at our
bellies go what do we doing there that's
smart well that's good how can we help
today did you guys uh resolve the card
issue did you contact the bank get the
card shut down the bank yep and we don't
have credit cards and just like you guys
said um full protection on that debit
card um they return the money it was
great um so just want to call and thank
you for um that gift to to Veterans um I
liked it shared it texted to every vet I
knew so um hopefully a bunch of them got
in there and got the same um gift from
Ramsey that I got um so just wanted to
call and say thank you guys love what
you're doing um I'm sharing and telling
everybody um about it that I can um
Ramsey and Jesus man that's all we got
to keep talking about well thank thank
you will we're honored that you called
in and thank you for your service and
sacrifice yeah it's man um it's a small
uh small price to pay would we give out
10,000 10,000 free financial peace
universities and every dollar to
families Y and we we ran out of which is
amazing I was excited that we actually
got 10,000 people to go to the site fill
out the form and people were sharing
this all over the country saying they
have veterans in their life they want to
take advantage of this and they did it
yeah I saw this inside this the the
student loan industry when I was working
at higher ed at how many universities um
profit for-profit and otherwise prey on
Veterans and so this idea that we're
going to give them a tool is really I'm
glad to be associated with a team that
does that but let's not put the um let's
not put the spotlight on on the wrong
thing it is much easier to give out
a the greatest budgeting app on the
planet it's much easier to give out an
app than it is to tell your family for
20 or 30 years I'm going to go serve
something way bigger than myself I'm
going to go serve people that I don't
even know so on behalf of me and George
and our wives and our kids thank you
thank you to Will and thank you for to
the 10,000 veterans and to the thousands
and thousands and countless others who
continually um raise their hand when
everyone else is staring at their shoes
they raise their hand and they say I
will I'm in thank you so much will I'm
grateful for you brother let's go out to
rihan in Palm Springs what's up how we
doing hey guys how are you good we're up
against the clock so get right to your
question yes yes I have a really quick
question regarding baby step three I'm
in baby step two I have a unique living
situation I don't have any rent or any
real expenses so I'm not sure how much I
should be saving for my baby step 3 and
also because I live in Southern
California and our home prices are
outrageous and my age I'm 46 like what
can I do where do I know when to start
saving for the home and how much to
start saving or how much to have for my
3 to six months living expenses how much
more debt do you
have I'm only in about $20,000 worth of
debt it's just like lingering uh only
that's a lot of debt to me I'd want to
be out is it is it is I'm I'm doing my
best I'm in baby step 2 I'm motivated I
have Financial Peace University like I'm
into to it awesome what's your
income my income is uh 52,000 a year
okay and with very little expenses um
how quickly can you pay this 20K off if
you get aggressive um I'm looking I'm
looking at um summer of 2024 if not
earlier okay so we're talking eight
months or so yeah because I've already
paused my 401k contributions as well oh
wonderful okay so you're going to be
throwing you know two or three grand at
this debt making 52 with no rent okay
and your question is what do I save up
for the emergency fund um you're going
are you going to have rent in the
foreseeable future yeah where do you
live um well I live in Southern
California I live in Palm Springs so I
do live in a retire like a resort
community so everything is really
expensive here I do want to buy here
though this is where I want to make my
home but where are you living like
physically right now oh where I'm living
um my boy I live with my boyfriend um
his parents have they own a condo here
and they're really generous they like us
to live here because they like having
somebody here so it's really given me a
great opportunity to just save save save
save and pay off payoff payoff but I do
want my own place eventually yes this is
one of those gravy trains that ends
suddenly yes yes and I don't want to
take it you know I don't want to be here
forever I want my own home okay what do
homes around their cost that you would
want let's say a condo for you if we're
going to be realistic condo um
probably I would say well over 200,000
if not inching towards 300 okay so let's
say you have a goal of
300,000 so now we have a down payment
savings goal and you want to get a
15-year fixed rate mortgage where the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay and so as you start
to do that math it will help dictate how
much down payment you're going to need
now that for you that might be a $6,000
down payment and that might mean we have
to increase our income so that we can
accomplish this goal in a reasonable
amount of of time let's say five
years okay let's say you could save 15
grand for five years or 20 grand for
three or four years that will help you
get there faster if you can increase
that income and keep your expenses
down okay but that's a great goal once
you have your emergency fund and you
have no debt that's the time to start
saving up for that house now does my age
play into that because I am 46 I just
turned 46 and I know it can be different
when you're at at my age in life like
doing the is it going to an impact my
future that's kind of no the only reason
age would play a factor is you may want
to be investing for retirement while you
save up for the down payment so that
might slow down your down payment but
it'll also help you retire with
dignity so I balance those yeah and I
know this is frustrating for some folks
but my mom didn't start her second Wing
until she was 53 and ended up with a
whole backend career that was amazing so
um keep after it I want to thank
everybody in the booth for helping the
show Even You Z hen George great job as
always congratulations on continuing to
pre-sell an amazing book and thank you
America for joining us in a world gone
mad choose Freedom choose to live
debt-free and choose compassion we'll
see you next
[Music]
time
a